الدكتور هاني المصري يعني على ما يبدو كل
ما همم استمعنا اليه اا او جاء به بلنكن
واستمعنا اليه من تصريحات في المؤتمر
الصحفي على الاقل يتطابق مع المطالب مع
الفلسطينيه كيف يمكن استغلال موقف اداره
بايدنا الان والبناء عليه
مع احترامي لك هذا غير صحيح بالمره اذا
اخذنا ما صرح في به لينك في مؤتمر الصحفي
يمكن ان نقول ان جوهر ما تحدث به هو
الحفاظ على الامن الاسرائيلي اولا هو اذان
العمليه الفلسطينيه ووصفها بالارهابيه
بعبارات شديده جدا هو طالب بتعميق اتفاقات
ابراها
لتثبيت وتقويه الامن الاسرائيلي هو التزم
بعدم حصول ايران على القنبله النوويه
حفاظا على الامن الاسرائيلي هو يعني كل ما
قاله حتى عندما يطالب بحل دولهتين ليس لان
هذا حق للفلسطينيين حتى يتم حمايه الامن
الاسرائيلي وحمايه اسرائيل كدوله يهوديه
اذن نحن نجد ان الولايات المتحده كما كانت
في ال- في العاده يعني هي منحاذه كليا
لاسرائيل وقال ايضا انها
مهما تكن هذه الحكومه همم في اسرائيل
ملتزمه الولايات المتحده بدعم الامن
الاسرائيلي حتى لو كانت حكومه فاشيه حتى
لو كانت حكومه ترتكب الاجرام في كل يوم
اما فيما يتعلق
بالمطالبه باجراءات للتهدئه او بالمطالبه
بالديمقراطيه في اسرائيل فهي مثل الاب
الحريص على ابنه عندما يخطئ يعني من من
واقع الحرص على المصلحه الاسرائيليه لا
تريد الولايات المتحده لهذه الحكومه ان
تمضي بعيدا في جرائمها على سبيل المثال لم
يرى بلينكن انه في ليله واحده قامت يعني
قطعان المستوطنين بارتكاب 150 هجوم في
جنوب نابلس على سيارات وممتلكات ومزارع
واشخاص في ليله واحده وفي في القدس تجري
عمليه من الاغلاقات ومن هدم المنازل ومن
التهديدات وفي كل يوم تقر الكنيسه قوانين
عنصريه متطرفه لا تراها الادا امريكيه ولا
تنظر لها على الاطلاق بل على العكس انتقدت
قرار القياده الفلسطينيه بوقف التنسيق
الامريكي وانتقدت توجه
السلطه الفلسطينيه والفلسطينيين الى
المحاكم الدوليه والى الامم المتحده ولاء
وترفض توفير الحمايه للفلسطينيين وتتعامل
مع اسرائيل كانها الضحيه الم تسمعي بايدن
ماذا قال عن الهجوم في القدس قال انه هجوم
ارهابي مروع وهجوم على الحضاره في العالم
هو طالب الاجهزه الامنيه الامريكيه بوضع
كل
قدراته في خدمه اسرائيل اذا لا يجب ان
نعول على هذه الاداره وهي ستضغط على
القياده الفلسطينيه ولم تضغط على اسرائيل
حتى تتراجع عن قرارتها التنسيق الامريكي
الفلسطيني